hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 2018
World Chess Championships in London
England between Magnus Carlsen and a
Fabiano Cara Juana we're all tied up
after four games we've had ever game end
in a draw which brings us to game number
five Fabiano playing the white pieces
looking to get on the board with win
versus Magnus Carlsen playing the black
pieces so we'll go and get into it
starts with the same thing we've been
seeing in the past pawn to e4 pawn c5
the Sicilian offense not f3 knight c6
you can probably guess what's coming
Bishop here to b5 g 6 but here's where
things start to get different normally
we've seen Fabiano take immediately with
bishop takes on c6 followed by pawn to
c6 that's not what we see here instead
we see Fabiano immediately castle on the
King side followed by Bishop here to g7
rook to e1 to protect this pawn on e4
pawn a5 and then we have the most
interesting move in my opinion so far in
the tournament's a lot of different
lines that Fabiano can take here he
decides to go for an extremely
aggressive and sharp line and that is
pawn to b4 a true gambit giving up a
pawn in material not gonna get that pawn
back anytime soon but he feels like he
can get a positional advantage giving up
that pawn now Magnus Carlsen has not
seen this except in 2005 one time he
played he was only 14 years old though
he does have a pretty good memory so he
may be familiar with that game but just
to see this type of play is something we
normally don't see in the World Chess
Championships a lot of GM's were
commentating we're tweeting about this
specific line saying they haven't seen
this sharp of an opening in a World
Championship and as far as they could
remember so very interesting to see
Fabiano it's tough to even know if he
spent the past couple games almost
setting up this one move he's been
playing that bishop here to b5 maybe I
could play a few games with Magnus
and again this is a 12-game series so
it's a marathon we have seen some drawls
but much of this is just figuring out
how your opponent's going to play could
all be setting up for something like
this pawn here to b4 to see how -
Carlsen is going to respond took about
four minutes Magnus Carlsen decides to
take with his knight could have also
taken with this pawn if he wants to then
pawns who a3 could see the Queen come
down here to b6 if it wants to attack
maybe the bishop takes here a lot of
variations within here but at the end
the day we see the Knights come down and
take on before now we see white play
Bishop to b2 Fein kettle on the Queen
side the board both the dark square
bishop and the night here on f3 are both
attacking this pawn here on e5 so a
couple options at Black has he can play
something to come back and protect this
or he can start to attack material for
him white he decides to go for the
latter place pawn to a6 attacking the
bishop and we see pawn to a3 now you may
see Bishop - II am ax stake cuz he's
gonna lose materials gonna start pushing
his pawns he doesn't actually end up
losing material really because this
night here on b4 so if he does play
Bishop here to a4 we could see pawn down
to b5 Bishop comes back here now pawn
down to c4 but then Y can play the pun -
a three-night comes back to c6 Bishop
comes to a2 so wall white didn't lose
material for playing Bishop to a4 you
can definitely tell that he has a much
worse position black has completely
blocking this in with his pawns right
here he's controlling the kun complete
center of the board
now both his knights and his bishop are
defending this pot this is a pretty good
setup that black has so Fabiano's not
looking to go down that path instead
plays pawn to a3 we see some exchanging
on the board pawn takes on b5 giving
black double pawns on the B file pawn
takes here rook comes down here a
bishops going to recapture on a
d6 just solidified the pawn chain a
little bit and then pawn takes on c5 and
Magnus Carlson's in a situation where he
has to come up with the right move here
because a lot of stuff's going on as far
as how he wants to continue the bishop
and the night are still both attacking
this pawn right now we have the pawn and
the bishop here from black but as soon
as he takes this all of a sudden that's
going to give up both of his central
pawns here since he's going to lose this
on e5 so if he were to take let's say
pawn takes on c5 then the bishop takes
bishop recaptures Knight takes here
maybe the knight to e7 Queen here to e2
not necessarily how black wants to
continue with no central pawns White has
both of his and there's double pawns
over here on the B file not the
situation Magnus Carlsen wants now if we
come back instead if we see just
something Knight to f6 just say yeah I'm
not too worried about this I still have
this pawn right here
okay so Knight to f6 well pawn can take
on d6 Queens egg so now there is that
extra defender but the Knights now
blocking the bishop so you don't want to
do that because now Bishop takes
attacking the Queen Queen can move pawn
up here to d4 you can see White's just
controlling the entire center of the
board so instead of coming to f6 does
not want to block off this bishop
instead we see Knight to e7 now Queen to
e2 attacking at this pawn here on a b5
pawn down here to b4 Queen up here to c4
wants to make sure when you see the pawn
here - before this is opening up the
door for the Queen to come down to a 5
this is attacking the bishop here on a1
as well as this pawn here on a c5 and it
only opens up that door after the pawn
moves down to b4 so white has to be
aware of that so in the game we do see
Fabiana bring his queen here to see for
preparing for his opponent that could
play to a5 Magnus Carlsen decides I'm
just gonna continue I still think a5 is
the best move not gonna give up that
material cuz Fabiano knew exactly what
was happening but that's the reason why
they were playing those Queens where
they were
besides now to take the material on d6
Bishop down to e6 you can defend this a
couple ways one of the ways just to
attack your opponent force him to move
back so the Queen is gonna come up here
to c7 the Queen takes here and then the
pawn
recapture so interesting in this
position yes both sides had double pawns
definitely not good for black to have
double pawns here on the B file with no
pawns on either side
why does have double pond's right here
he has a passed pawn on the C file but
you can see as far as just material is
concerned all of a sudden Fabiano is up
in material so gave up a pawn is a true
game it early on had a real good
position throughout the game so far and
now is actually up a pawn in material
now will be tough to hold on to that
material advantage if you look from
blacks perspective Holly needs to
continue
Magnus needs to first worry about this
pawn on e5 it is being attacked still by
both the bishop and the night here on f3
so he needs to get his knight involved
luckily for him he does have a great
square of Knight to c6 this not only
defends the square here on e5 it also
blocks off this pawn here on c7 c7 pawn
can't promote right away cuz the lights
were a bishop but also just blocks off
any other material coming to try to
protect that very easy now for the King
to get involved and gobble up that
material right here and then we would be
at parity then pawn to c3 received from
Fabiano and then King to d7 it's not
gonna make much sense for Magnus Carlsen
yes it would be a straight trade but you
know your opponent wants to get his
material bulbs to the game if you're
gonna trade you don't want to do
something like this because all of a
sudden white now has an extra tempo in
the game because he wants to be playing
this so force him to play you know the
pawn takes and then the knight takes and
then the knight takes okay well you know
have a knight that's more involved into
the game than if you hadn't so that's
just something to think about of why he
would play King to d7 instead of
thinking about trading here on the Queen
side with the pawns now the pawn takes
on b4 rook over here to
eight bishop to c3 and you know where
nineteen moves in now Fabiano took about
thirty minutes on this move move
nineteen it's interesting just four
moves ago we kind of looked at and saw
Fabiana had a good position he's that
material and then you could tell all of
a sudden a few moves later Fabiano feels
like his advantage has slipped away he's
not really sure even how he should
continue maybe he wants knowing that his
pawns going to leave maybe he wants to
push up get a queen right here force his
opponent to take this and then he feels
like maybe he can get another position
that's favorable in the game decides at
the end of day to play bishop here to c3
the king takes so we are equal in
material here pawn to d3 king here to b6
really safe square once the queen's come
off the board especially one of the
rooks as well you can really get your
kings involved they become a very
powerful piece in the middle to the in
game bishop down here it's a d2 rook to
d8 attacking this pawn backward pawn
here white has to worry about the
thinning that one of the ways as we
talked about is to attack a very
valuable piece king one of being one of
those that is putting your opponent
check so Bishop to e3 check King is
forced to move here to b5
Knight up here to c3 same thing check
forcing the opponents and move and then
King two before wants to make sure that
he doesn't avoid anything crazy yes he's
always gonna take this pawn on before
but if he does make a mistake King to a6
would end in checkmates rook over here
to a1 where does black really go from
here he can't move his King to be 5
because the knight can't move it here to
b6 because of the dark square bishop so
he's really just gonna be throwing
material away until it's checkmate
Bishop down here rook takes and then
Knight over here to a5 there's just no
other way to stop this rook takes on a5
this would be checkmate so even in these
small situations it is very important to
understand the best line and it just so
happens from Magnus Carlsen that he can
gobble up material so it takes the pawn
on b4 Knight comes up to d5 another
check right here we do see some
exchanging come on the board rook comes
down
takes on a d5 and then we're swings over
here b1 check to gobble up material here
on b7 so both sides again equal in
material that appear to d8 both
attacking the rook as well as defending
this square here on f7 so pretty
convenient square for Magnus Carlsen
rook to c7 check King takes here on d3
King to f1 just getting involved into
the game also doesn't want to worry
about any back rank makes for the rook
if it were to come down here pawn to h5
pawn to h3 came here to e4 I find this
kind of an odd move for Magnus Carlsen
he knows his opponents gonna be playing
Knight up here to g6 both check and
attacking this pawn on f7 which he's
also attacking with his rook but there's
just not a lot of squares for Magnus
Carlsen to go to I think he realizes in
this position it's a drawing game so
he's kind of speeding that up if you
will king to f5 Knight up here to f7 as
we talked about Knight takes the rook
takes this is check Bishop defends on f3
and after 33 moves the players decide to
go ahead and draw now there's definitely
some positions where I look at it and
say why would you draw it like you could
play on there may be something there in
this position I don't feel like there is
they pretty much move you know the last
10 moves just trading off material all
the way down till we got here so this is
the the fifth consecutive draw for me
personally I feel like this is the most
exciting one of the players actually
tried to play something very different
innovative for a lot of the game I feel
like it was working had a good advantage
Fabiana did a good job I feel like his
preparation paid off Magnus Carlsen
though just defended extremely well so I
do think we have to give kudos to manage
Carlsen he's the the world champion for
a reason he wasn't fazed at all I didn't
sit there spending 30 minutes looking
all distraught and he kind of looked to
the positions even afterwards they
interviewed him and said you know where
did you feel comfortable he said I felt
comfortable it didn't faze me at all I
felt good about the opening yes who was
a good line by Fabiano but the end of
the day Magnus Carlsen was not phased in
the release so at the end of it we had
a drawl both sides are tied magnus
carlsen will actually have the white
pieces in the next two games so he plays
white pieces tomorrow in Game six they
will take a rest day and then we kind of
do a reverse Magnus Carlsen will start
the second half with the white pieces
and then Fabiano with the black piece
and then on the next day Fabiano white
pieces and Fabiano will have the white
pieces in the final game round number 12
if we get to two that match we don't
know if we actually will but thank you
guys so much for watching Game five
hopefully enjoyed it thanks for watching
the commentary and I'll see you guys
tomorrow for game number six